physically I've learned how to peek
super properly like that will almost
never I feel like being an issue for me
because I figured that piece out the
camps are talking about physical
training making sure your body's not
worn down making sure it's not worn down
making sure that I'm doing the weight
cut correctly putting the weight back on
correctly those are like uh the the
physical piece is easy because it's like
I did this I did this that's black and
white that's pretty black and white the
mental side is where we don't have a
scale for those types of things because
it's a lot harder to uh just there is no
like you step on the scale there's a
number okay I'm losing weight there
isn't that with the brain